these are violent attacks recorded in
Africa in the first five months of 2018
Munir by groups fighting in the ongoing
civil wars in South Sudan and the
Central African Republic others are
riots against government's in
southeastern Africa but these are
different their attacks by Islamist
militant groups some claim to be
branches of the Islamic state while
others claim to be al-qaeda both groups
are usually associated with the Middle
East but for the past decade Islamist
militant groups have been spreading
across Africa where they've continued to
find places to organize and launch
attacks their successes push these
fragile States into deeper turmoil and
it's made the region one of the most
dangerous in the world to understand how
these terrorist groups got to Africa and
why they're so successful there it helps
us start in Nigeria Nigeria has the
biggest population and economy in Africa
wealth industry and major cities are
mostly in the south while the north is
poor marginalized isolated and home to
most of Nigeria's Muslim population it
was here that a radical Islamist group
called Boko Haram took shape and turned
violent in 2009 they started raising
villages slaughtered men and women and
kidnapped children who were forced to
carry out suicide attacks
the Nigerian government cracked down but
the group continued to grow in 2014 they
got international attention when they
kidnapped close to 300 schoolgirls in
chiva by then they controlled a huge
swath of territory in northern Nigeria
where they imposed strict Sharia law and
declared it an Islamic caliphate in 2015
they became affiliated with the Islamic
state which had a Caliphate of its own
in Iraq and Syria within a few years the
group killed nearly 25,000 people and
was on track to become the deadliest
terror group in the world eventually
surpassing Isis five African countries
backed by the US UK and France formed a
task force to battle Boko Haram by April
2015 they deliberated major towns and
seemed to push Boko Haram out but three
years later Boko Haram is still active
the group had shifted its focus to the
lake chad region one of the poorest
places in the world the lake touches the
borders of Nigeria and Nigeria Chad and
Cameroon but none of the state
governments have any real presence here
this is where Boko Haram is operating
they've been raiding local villages for
food and capturing men to serve as
fighters in 2016 the group split into
two as Boko Haram's attacks grew more
and more violent this group the Islamic
state was Africa started offering
protection of villages in danger they
also provided stability and even water
supplies to a region collapsing under a
food crisis in exchange for attacks and
recruits in the absence of a strong
central government they moved further
into Nigeria and new share where they've
launched attacks of their own and are
officially affiliated with the Islamic
state exploiting and terrorizing locals
in uncovered areas has become a
successful strategy keeping these
militant groups active but it doesn't
stop here the strategy is being used by
terrorists all across the continent
lake chad is part of the Sahel a narrow
band of territory that stretches across
north-central Africa the conditions that
make like Chad ideal for Boko Haram and
iswa
extend across this whole region the
population is mostly Muslim and
vulnerable ethnic conflicts are rampant
food is scarce poverty is rife and most
importantly there's almost no presence
of a government Islamist militant groups
have been filling these spaces at a
staggering pace seven years ago Islamist
militant groups took over northern Mali
and declared it a Caliphate for 10
months before a French military
intervention drove them back into the
desert today they've banded together and
are affiliated with al-qaeda a group
called is G s broke away and is now
affiliated with the Islamic state this
part of Mali remains uncovered and
violent seven years after the
intervention both of these groups are
fighting for various militias in the
conflict meanwhile both are attacking
foreigners including the French Embassy
in 2018 and the 2017 ambush of the US
special forces in BG air that 12 US
soldiers mostly green berets were
ambushed by a larger force of Isis
linked militant Islamist militant groups
are finding success in other uncovered
spaces as well Isis claims to have
launched ten attacks in 2018 in Libya
where a civil war has raged since 2011
in Somalia and Isis affiliated groups
split from al-shabaab an al-qaeda group
it's made this whole part of Africa one
of the most dangerous places in the
world the US and France have both
stepped up their presence with several
military bases across the Sahel
but drone strikes and Special Forces
alone are not the solution to the
Islamist terrorism in Africa as long as
there are places with poverty conflicts
and no government terrorist groups will
be here
[Music]